what's Poppin Rebels it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
Ahsoka episode 6 featured the arrival of
Morgan ellsbeth's team to the Far Far
Away planet of paridia just so we could
see the much awaited return of grand
Admiral thrawn wearing his Grand Admiral
thrawn outfit but how exactly could
Winnie Sarah and Mary be helping thrawn
and why like what is the end game of
these three Knight sisters and what
Mysteries could this mysterious temple
on paridia hold and how could those
Mysteries be linked to the type of power
that balance skull is chasing after
let's dive into it all together fam
alright gang I'm gonna start this video
off by talking about the actual building
that thrawn and the Knight sisters call
their home base because out of
everything in this super exciting
episode this Temple itself has got me
the most hype mostly because of its
connection to the mysterious alien race
known as the zepho an alien race that I
am so obsessed with ever since I played
Jedi Fallen order if you've watched one
of my previous videos where I actually
connect the star map ruins from episode
1 to the zephal race as you can see
links to the zepho on the walls as well
as the outside pillars then you won't be
too surprised when I tell you guys that
there is even more evidence for the
zepho in episode 6. during the scene
when thrawn is watching Sabine leave the
mysterious Temple his army is based at
we can see what appears to be zephonian
runes carved on the outside walls of
that Temple very much implying that the
planet of paridia is one of the planets
that the force attuned zepho race have
called home at one point now if you
don't know who the zepho are that's okay
I got you boo not everyone plays video
games after all only the cool people
that don't have girlfriends like me
please kill me
I'm just kidding in Star Wars Jedi
Fallen order the Jedi calcastus Ventures
into various tombs of ancient zephal
leaders while following the trail of
Jedi archaeologist Eno Cordova I
freaking love this man and I was so
upset when spoiler alert freaking bowed
murdered him in Jedi Survivor I'm gonna
say the f word but I can't just kidding
[__] boat I made sure to send that
[__] to Hell myself Anna Cordova
is actually one of my favorite Jedi in
all of Star Wars because he was a Jedi
that was obsessed with Unlocking The
Mysteries of the distant past in order
to better understand the force in
particular the ancient customs and
belief of the zepho were a race of
people with a crazy deep understanding
of the force even more so than Cordova's
Jedi Order Eno Cordova spent a
ridiculous amount of his time exploring
different planets with zephoto tombs in
them in search of golden circular
objects called astrum so he could use
those astriums to unlock an ancient
zephal Vault of Secrets located on the
Planet bogana lots of cute animals there
now there are two big reasons why this
is important to the overall Ahsoka
narrative the first one being that the
protagonist of Fallen order calcus
eventually finds one of these zephonian
astroms inside of the Tomb of the dark
side zephosage kujet on the dark-sided
planet of dathomir the same planet that
the knights sisters took over long after
the zepho abandoned that planet strongly
linking the Knight sisters to zephal
culture as both zethonian planets of
dathomir and paridia have coincidentally
been taken over by the night sisters and
the second reason why this zepho
connection is important has to do with
the hidden Force message that the zepho
Left Behind in the form of a vision for
whoever managed to open the astrum vault
on bogano like calcasus eventually does
in that forced Vision the zepho tell Cal
that they were ashamed that they lost
their way over the course of their time
in the Star Wars Galaxy and honestly
they were right to feel that shame
because as Cal goes through each of
those zepho tombs in that game team the
player can get a clear sense of how the
zepho culture slowly descended into the
dark side over the course of their
history going from a culture that had a
deep respect for life and the living
force during the days that they were
ruled by the zephosage elrim to a
culture of greed suffering and death
under the rule of zephosage kujet the
very same Sage that held the astrium
that calcustus eventually receives from
kujet's tomb on dathomir in fact as you
approach kujet's tomb in the game you
can see the ashy remains of the zepho
who tried to take kujet's power away
from him and I don't mean ashy like they
forgot to use some Jurgens brand lotion
kujet apparently used the dark side of
the force to completely wipe out a bunch
of his zepho people by turning those
pesky Rebels into literal Ash so yeah
the zepho definitely lost their way and
because of this calcus learns that the
zepho decided to leave the Star Wars
Galaxy completely to venture into
regions unknown in order for their race
to get a fresh new start which basically
means that they ventured off into a
Galaxy far far away this all being said
I have a strong feeling that the
pyridian Galaxy is where the zepho
eventually landed with paridia being one
of the zepho's new homes for that fresh
start knowing this we might possibly be
able to deduce a number of things for
the future of the series things like
what the night sister desire out of
their relationship with thrawn what Bale
and skull desires with the planet of
paridia in general and how Sabine and
Ezra could potentially make their way
back to their home Galaxy if they were
to get stranded but let's start with
trying to address what the end game of
the night sisters could be and I think
the answer to that question lies within
the very catacombs under the surface of
the planet itself during episode 6
thrawn mentions a transfer of cargo from
these catacombs to his ship that the
golden face Enoch was in charge of
overseeing and that the night sisters
catacomb cargo was so damn large that it
would take all of his soldiers a full
three days to get on board the ship
enthron does note that this transfer of
cargo is in large part to the agreement
that he made with these three Knight
sisters implying to me me that this
mysterious cargo has little to do with
thrawn's own aspirations and more to do
with the Knight sisters wanting to bring
these pieces of pyridia back with them
to the Star Wars Galaxy but also since
we know that paridia is a zephonian
planet much like daphomir is there is a
good chance that these Knight sisters
are raiding the tomb of yet another
ancient zepho sage and stealing a bunch
of force artifacts for themselves much
like the emperor ordered his
Stormtroopers to do on zephaloplanets in
Fallen order it seems to me that like
Palpatine the true motives of the night
sisters might be directly linked to
unlocking the hidden Dark Side secrets
of the force that the zepho may have
left behind Within These artifacts
secrets that could potentially pose a
great threat to the Star Wars Galaxy At
Large and possibly lead to the Knight
sisters gaining a lot more Galactic
power and influence after living in the
shadows of dathomir for so long and
since the building that they are
stationed in appears to be a zepho
temple of some kind I'm willing to bet
that the very entrance to these
underground catacombs lie within this
tall ass town itself however I also have
a feeling that in exchange for thrawn's
help with bringing these Treasures back
the nine sisters have used their dark
magic to provide thrawn with his new
Knight Trooper Army of the undead that's
right everybody I think that all of
these oddly stoic night Troopers are
actually just more night sister gas
inside of empty stormtrooper armor you
know just like Merrick ended up being
one percent evil and 99 hot gas with the
red Knight sister fabric added to their
suits to symbolize the night sister's
influence because from what I can tell
green knight's sister magic appears to
be strongly linked to the living Force
more specifically the dark side of the
living Force which is just a fancy way
of saying the death Force because death
is the dark side of life but the death
force is not a Star Wars term of course
I just made it up living beings embody
the light side of the living Force while
reanimated dead beings like Merrick or
the undead night sisters from Fallen
order represents the dark side of the
living Force Knight sisters in Star Wars
appear here to draw all of their power
from the energies within their home
planet itself energies that happen to be
linked to all the dead Knight sisters
whose bodies have been buried inside of
the planet of daphomir because you gotta
remember what Ahsoka mentioned earlier
in the season about every living being
having the force living inside of them
so when night sisters or Knight Brothers
die on dathomir The Living force that
once empowered their existence while
they were living transfers into the
actual planet and becomes one with it
allowing for living night sisters to
manipulate and use that dead life force
energy for their magic which is why the
night sisters are at their most
strongest while physically standing on
their home planet of dathomir and Sabine
herself is no stranger to one of the
best examples of knight's sister death
Force energy in action as she has been
possessed by the undead Spirit of a
night sister along with Kanan after
visiting a night sister temple on
daftamere in episode 11 of rebels season
3. in a similar way I have a feeling
that all of thrawn's night troopers were
all replaced by this green living four
souls of dead death of Miriam Knight
sisters and Knight Brothers that have
died on paridia because remember all
those coffin-like objects that we see
the night Troopers loading onto thrawn
ship I strongly believe that these are
all the coffins of the Stormtroopers who
have died on paridia and thrawn being
the military man that he is is making
sure that all of his soldiers get the
proper burials they deserve on their
respective homeworlds when he gets back
because if you think about it peridia is
a massive Wasteland of a planet with
barely any resources to feed one man let
alone an entire Army of stranded
Stormtroopers most if not all of
thrawn's army likely perished at some
point in the past from the planet's
harsh conditions whether from starvation
or being you know killed or mall to
death by a howler however since thrawn
has a strong background in survival he
somehow managed to be the last one
standing though I wouldn't exactly be
surprised if he himself was also
resurrected by the Knight sisters in
order for them to get a ride off of the
planet through Morgan ellsbeth but like
I said before the zephos influence could
also serve to explain what baylen's
mystery serious motives are as well
because during his conversation with the
wonderful and perfect shinhati who has
done nothing wrong with this entire
series and I will defend her in court
Balin mentions that he is extremely
frustrated with how history keeps
repeating itself in a maddening dance
between the forces of light and darkness
in the Galaxy the fall of the Republic
and the rise of the Empire by the end of
the Clone Wars and the fall of the
Empire and the rise of the new Republic
at the end of the Galactic Civil War
were just the latest examples of an
unending cosmic power struggle between
light and darkness in the cosmos and
much like the Jedi archaeologist Anna
Cordova Balan skull is very likely
familiar with the past history of the
zepho culture from his time learning
history from the Jedi archive on
Coruscant especially how these zepho
races own rise fall and eventual Journey
towards Redemption long ago was just
another indicator of this seemingly
never-ending Cosmic struggle between
Darkness and Light a struggle that I
believe balen seeks to end completely by
following whatever force is calling to
him on the planet of paridia a force I
believe leave could be strongly linked
to the powerful force-wielding zepho of
the past Balon says in this episode that
he's seeking the beginning in order to
put an end to this incessant cycle in
that specific phrasing leads me to
believe that Balin may actually be
looking for a way to get into the world
Between Worlds itself because much like
we learn in Star Wars Rebels the world
Between Worlds does allow for the
facilitation of time travel a benefit
that Ahsoka Tano herself owes her life
to courtesy of Ezra Bridger and seeing
as Ahsoka appears to have gotten access
to the world Between Worlds specifically
after burning her hand on the star map
to the zepholinked paridia it wouldn't
be too much of a stretch to assume that
the zepho built a temple that could
access the world Between Worlds itself
in fact I have a feeling that Star Wars
Rebels teases this during the first
appearance of the world Between Worlds
because a couple of weeks ago I tweeted
that one of the gates that Ezra walks
past in that episode actually has the
symbol of the zepho sage Trinity on the
very top of the door but until episode 6
of Ahsoka I had no idea what these
animal constellations decorated on the
left and rights of the doorway could be
I've never seen this weird looking
animal before in Star Wars however if I
were to guess now this four-legged
constellation might be one of the
howlers of paridia much like how the
loath Wolves of lothal were represented
by their own world between World
constellations this all being said I
believe there is at least one temple on
paridia that could potentially lead to
the specific Gateway inside of the world
Between Worlds and hell it could even be
that Temple that we see thrawn and
Morgan ellsbeth stationed at I have a
feeling that whatever force is guiding
bailing is also tempting him with the
knowledge of how to reshape the entire
Cosmos from the very beginning of the
cosmic conflict Itself by leading him to
a door to the world Between Worlds
because much like Balin says in the
episode despite him growing to resent
the Jedi balen actually did admire what
the Jedi were originally supposed to
stand for the Quest for Galactic peace
and the overall balancing of the light
and dark sides of the force I think
Balin is trying to achieve that balance
of the force by going back in time and
ending whatever Force set the
never-ending Star Wars in the galaxy in
motion from the beginning of time or
even possibly by the world Between
Worlds revealing to Balin how he could
become the most powerful force wielder
to ever live so he could sustain Cosmic
order himself but either way I have a
hunch that the zephos links to the world
Between Worlds holds the ticket to True
power that balen's been looking for this
entire time but the added bonus here is
that if peridia does in fact hold a
gateway to the world Between Worlds both
Ezra and Sabine could potentially use
this paridian gateway to get back home
if they do end up being stranded but we
shall see in due time God I really do
love this show Dave filoni deserves all
the success and more and infinite
[__] because Dave filoni is super
smart but anyways thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at Mass retainment on Twitter and
Instagram or wherever I am on the
internet but most importantly do not
forget to subscribe to heavy spoilers
today because we have a lot of amazing
stuff coming to you guys all the time
I'm working on a really great Spider-Man
2002 breakdown that I cannot wait for
you guys to see very soon but anyways
you guys are the best and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye